[Music]
[Applause]
this is the bailey ball pit cocktail bar
in shoreditch east london where freedom
day
means fireworks dancing and mingling in
a room of plastic balls
but for the founder celebrations have
been dampened by today's announcement
i don't think it gives the gov you know
my customers great confidence that
they're saying freedom day off you go
and they're suddenly talking about
double jabs to get into nightclubs it's
you know it will scare away the
customers
this is the buttermarket nightclub in
shrewsbury opening last night
but today the government message was
very much that there's no such thing
as a covid safe dance floor right the
way across the world we've seen that
nightclubs and venues where you've got
lots of people
indoors crowded together
are a focus for potential super
spreading events
and that has also been seen in terms of
what's happened in holland and israel
where nightclubs opened and you saw a
big increase in cases
and so the government will insist that
clubbers such as these ones in liverpool
will have to be double jabbed with
vaccination passports to gain entry
come the end of september the messaging
is so irresponsible now for the next
48 hours people are going to have so
many questions
for an industry that's already on its
knees you know do you have to have
a double jab at the end of september if
you work in this industry
have you now lost your job i think it's
ill-thought-off
it's ill-conceived the nighttime economy
has been badly hit by covid one of the
first sectors to be shut down by the
government one of the last
to reopen but when they reopened it in
the netherlands there was an eightfold
increase in covid cases
and they had to reverse the decision
this appears to be an attempt
to stop that happening here it's a bit
odd but it's kind of necessary
to make sure that everybody is safe and
vaccinated it's a good idea but i just
don't know if it's going to be executed
very well
i think it's a good idea but i also know
some people might not agree with that
the nighttime economy generates billions
and including restaurants and theaters
accounts for eight percent of the
country's employment it is already
in deep trouble
and many industry figures feel the
government messaging
is sinking it further jason farrell
sky news